much so anyway let's get this going
and we're starting with a bit of an
unusual opening in the first game
it's called the greek norwegian
now let's see how he responds to it
okay so if i go d4
i'm blundering a pawn so i'll go bishop
b5 instead
seven
then i can go d4 right
and kind of go d4 now a6
um i don't have to take on c6 so i
probably won't
if he goes b5 bishop b3 takes d4 takes
the four knight of five i'll go knight
e2
and i sort of serve protect everything
as far as i can see okay it goes knight
f5 immediately
can take a c6 but
there's probably no particular reason to
let's see
i think i'm doing okay if i go knight e2
b5 mission p3
take d4 take queen check
g3 would take we exchanged everything on
d4 then i think on d5
i think i'm really ok
the bishop d6 i think i'll take on c6
and then bishop four
or maybe even bishop or immediately i
don't know
maybe i can even do something like c3
c3 castles knight d2
then knight f1 next
well you know what having
started out playing in such a
provocative way i think i should
continue
yeah knight f1
and
so after this bishop c2
and i feel like long term my prospects
aren't that bad
like i guess he's
he's a little bit better but i don't
think it's anything special
so i'll go g3 now
you can try and do something violent
but i'm i'm not particularly worried
about it
i mean like rookie 2 queen e2
then bishop g3
and uh capture everything but i feel
like
worst case i can just take back on g3
and then after queen h1 i go queen f1
and um i serve protect everything and
then start to develop
so now after queen of six i think i
should go fish before
and uh i think i'm
pretty happy that he played queen h4
because i do get this bishop f4 move
and
then i'm sort of server consolidating
97 that's
perfectly logical of course okay
um actually i don't need to take yet
can go queen d2 this bishop b5 in there
okay i'll just take on these
and then 93 i think
i feel like my position is is quite okay
um
i'm spending a little bit too much time
but i i believe it will be
fine okay now i guess i'll go for rookie
one
or maybe i'll go knight f4 first i think
my
first it trades on c2 i just take back
of course rookie one now
and i guess
the slightly weakened position of my
king means that he's
a little bit better but i'm not at all
worried
yeah so it tries to exploit exactly that
um i think i'll just go h4
and i'm just claiming that i'm gaining
space rather than
creating weaknesses i'll take an f5 now
knight g4
and queen d3
now i think i'm fairly well mobilized
we'll go v3 i don't
see the major issues there
okay a4
and i just blundered d3 that is just
insane
way to ruin a decent game huh
what have i done
what have i done queen d2
followed by
okay i guess i'll try it followed by
95 if i get a chance
obviously i'm grasping at straws now
okay he just lost the queen along
it's getting a little bit desperate now
that has to be said
we move along g4
and get our pieces into to play but i'm
just
i'm just upon down for nothing basically
okay and i don't have
i have a lot of squares for for my
pieces
this is just to create some confusion
okay rookie one i think i probably just
ended up self pinning here
okay he wants to trade i don't think we
can do much about that
trade d3
it's trying to make a draw
somehow somewhere okay 95
oh that is clever he doesn't take
okay just wait for now
yeah i didn't have to didn't actually
have to respond to that
oh i'm not so sure about this i give a
check the rook f6 was
was pretty bad
it's actually really really bad
now i'm back in the game
i take takes c6
i'm doing quite alright okay we'll give
a check
d7 obviously the time situation is a bit
it's a bit desperate now 975
i think
i could have gone b5 there probably
would not have been good news for me
five it just comes down to
hustle straight also
i missed 96 damage
but he had to move his pawns
okay
let's see for one ending is probably
nowhere
not good it's not trying to arrange f4
instead
push
it still pushes the plant
uh i guess this is probably a drama
we'll try we'll try and trick him
somehow
three
not giving him a draw quite yet okay g7
if it takes like push here i've got 95
now g8 i think is the only one
you lost some time good stuff
good stuff what a bad game
but i like the end um so at the end if
it goes king h6
i got
uh if he goes king h6 i got knight g4
and if he goes knight g8 i go d5 king f6
and then
d6 so my position may actually have been
winning
who knows anyway some nice
trickery there